coupez le 18 novembre 1990 à 18 heures
heure locale
florence arthaud 33 ans remporte la 4e
route du rhum après une traversée épique
de 18 jours à bord d'un trimaran de 18 m
elle est la première femme à remporter
une transatlantique en solitaire cette
victoire elle en rêvait depuis 12 ans
les français découvrent la jeune
navigatrice en 1978 lors de la première
édition de la route du rhum reliant
saint-malo à pointe-à-pitre en
guadeloupe
à 21 ans la benjamine de l'épreuve est
aussi la première femme à participer à
une transatlantique
j'aime le bateau gens n'avaient guère
envie de naviguer seul
en course et en solitaire en plus c'est
intéressant simple parce que c'est là
c'est une expérience voir quels sont nos
limites je peux aller et elle va aller
très loin
cette année là celle qu'on surnomme
désormais la petite fiancée de
l'atlantique arrivent 11e pour la
seconde édition de la route du rhum elle
devient la première femme du monde à
barrer un trimaran malgré une panne de
pilote automatique
florence arthaud se classe à la 20e
place suscitant l'admiration
florence arthaud dont chacun reconnaît
qu'elle est skipper avant d'être femme
disons navigateur avec la féminité en
plus
en 1986 la course est endeuillée par le
chavirage de loïc caradec florence se
déroute pour lui porter secours mais
découvre le catamaran vide
malgré ce drame elle arrive 11e en
guadeloupe
nouvel exploit mais déception pour la
navigatrice qui rêvait de victoire ben
c'est raté encore un effort et fois que
je commence dans quatre ans quoi en 1990
florence est au rendez vous avec son
trimaran pierre 1er mai cette fois c'est
sa santé qui flanche
elle souffre d'une hernie discale contre
avis médical elle s'embarque pour une
transat très compliqué j'ai complètement
crevé compagne de communication pendant
dix jours
elles ignorent qu'elles mènent la course
en tête c'est l'équipe de l'émission
thalassa qui lui apprend la bonne
nouvelle
florence arthaud arrive trois jours plus
tard à pointe à pitre le 18 novembre
1990 après 14 jours dix heures et huit
minutes de navigation
j'ai été franchement pas là j'ai cru que
j'allais mourir j'ai fait j'ai même
failli abandonner
et puis je me suis dit non non ça
prendrait pas si jamais abandonné ses
produits que j'ai commencé
florence arthaud est décédé en 2015 dans
un accident d'hélicoptère dans une
émission de télé réalité
[Musique]